Why are Proper Sterlization Procedures Used
During Lethal Injections?
Besides the fact that manufacturers sterilize
the needles (so no real extra effort is needed),
other sterilization procedures are also used
in these executions for good reason.
You see, a stay of execution may happen at
the last minute.
If this happens, but then the condemned later
dies from infection, a wrongful death suit
could be filed against the state -a suit the
state would likely lose.
While this may seem like a scenario that is
unlikely to occur in real life, in fact, this
is not the case at all.
Relatively last minute granting of a stay
of execution is incredibly common, though
ones where the needle is already inserted
are rare.
That being said, it has happened before.
Exhibit A: James David Autry.
Autry was convicted of murdering convenience
store employee Shirley Drouet and customer
Joe Broussard, who was in the store at the
time.
Another customer in the store was Anthanasios
Svarnas, who was shot, but not killed.
What did Autry get out of this?
Some beer worth $2.70 (about $7.41 today);
he didn’t take any money from the cash register,
just the beer.
About three years after the murders, on October
4, 1983, Autry found himself strapped down
with a needle in his arm, about to be injected
with a concoction of chemicals that would
end his life.
However, at the time, there was a question
whether Texas’ exact procedure for executions
was constitutional.
After lying there for a little over a half
hour, the call came in.
The Supreme Court had ruled that Autry’s
execution be delayed for 30 days while they
continued to review the issue.
The needle was removed and Autry was taken
back to his cell.
Of course, five months later, on March 14,
1984, he was executed.
But in the interim, had they not used proper
sterilization procedures, he may well have
gotten sick or even died as a result.
It’s considered okay for some states to
kill condemned prisoners in a properly vetted
procedure, but not via infection.
Yet another ultra-close call case is that
of Warren Lee Hill, a man with the IQ of just
70.
Hill received a life sentence for murdering
his girlfriend in 1985.
Five years later, he beat another inmate,
Joseph Handspike, to death and was given the
death penalty.
In July of 2012, just a few hours before he
was to be executed, he was given a stay of
execution.
Later, on February 19, 2013, he was once again
to be executed -this time, a stay of execution
was granted a scant 30 minutes before he was
to have the lethal concoction of chemicals
course through his veins.
To date, he has received four stays of executions
and as of the publication of this article,
he hasn’t been executed yet.
In as close of a call as you can get -though
this time the individual was not subject to
lethal injection -Caryl Chessman was given
a stay of execution so near to the set execution
time that it ended up being too late.
In 1948, Chessman, who’d robbed various
people and raped several women, was sentenced
to die via the gas chamber.
After garnering support from the likes of
Billy Graham and Eleanor Roosevelt, he was
granted eight stays of execution.
The problem was, in the last one, it occurred
about one minute before the execution was
to take place.
The secretary of the federal judge who’d
granted the stay accidentally dialed the wrong
number.
By the time she realized her mistake and called
the correct number, the cyanide pellets had
been dropped.
At this point, there was nothing that could
be done to stop the execution, and Chessman
died.
The lethal injection procedure usually employed
by prisons involves first introducing a saline
drip, then injecting the condemned with a
general anesthesia, hopefully which won’t
have worn off before the fatal fluids have
done their work.
Once the condemned is unconscious, some chemical
is used to cause death via cardiac arrest.
To achieve this, usually Pancuronium bromide
is injected, resulting in the individual ceasing
breathing.
After the Pancuronium bromide is introduced,
Potassium chloride comes next, which stops
the heart.